[Musique]
avec vous hélène frade bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour colline à la une de la
presse donc on en parlait à l'instant ce
sommet mini sommet organisé aujourd'hui
à l'elysée où emmanuel macron va
recevoir plusieurs dirigeants européens
et africains pour acter
vraisemblablement la fin des opérations
barkan est à kouba au mali le mali c'est
fini le journal d'opinion précise que
tous les détails de ce désengagement
n'ont pas encore été fixée mais que la
décision politique est prise le piège
est refermé la france n'a pas d'autre
solution que de quitter le mali avec un
sentiment d'échec que les éléments de
langage ne parviendront pas à masquer
écrit le journal ou le dessin de cas
qu'on le voit montre emmanuel macron
tournant le dos au nouvel homme fort du
mali le putschiste assimi gweltas qui
n'a pas été conviés à ce sommet et
auquel la candidate à la présidentielle
christiane taubira propose d'organiser
une petite primaire populaire la france
abandonne le mali aux djihadistes et aux
mercenaires de poutine au royaume uni
qui a envoyé des soldats dans le cadre
de la minus ma la mission de l'onu la
décision française passe mal les troupes
britanniques déployées dans ce qui est
déjà considérée comme la mission de
maintien de la paix la plus dangereuse
au monde seront ainsi plus exposés aux
attaques djihadistes critique de times
après des mois d'escaladé verbale entre
paris et bamako ce retrait qui sera
officialisée à priori tout à l'heure où
dans les heures à venir n'est pas
vraiment une surprise il ne fallait pas
être un bookmaker politiques
exceptionnelles pour voir arriver la
rupture entre les deux partenaires
historiques wakat serra annonce le
redéploiement et la réorganisation de
barkan est à kouba au sahel quand
quelqu'un laisse quelqu'un prend
philosophe le site burkinabè qui fait
état de la demande très forte des états
de la région pour reprendre cette
opération marque anne dont le mali ne
veut plus
waka de sarah qui note au passage que
qu'emmanuel ma croix a pris soir ce soir
deux convié le président du conseil le
chef de la diplomatie européenne pour ne
plus aller au front tout seul le
président français l'entente est
confrontée à la crise malienne il est
aussi à la crise en ukraine et pour le
temps cette situation géopolitique exige
qu emmanuel macron clarifie les choses
en officialisant enfin sa candidature à
la présidentielle croire que joe biden
vadimir poutine le président ukrainien
la junte militaire malienne où les
dirigeants de pays européens n'ont pas
anticipé sa conduite sa candidature
prochaine et la fragilité qui va en
découler est une illusion prévient le
journal suisse qui estime que les 48
millions d'électeurs français ont aussi
le droit de savoir si le chef des armées
va demain solliciter leurs suffrages
édito signé richard wehrli qui est le
correspondant à ici en france du
quotidien suisse lui pour le coup n'a
sollicité une personne pour prendre sa
décision en tunisie le président kaïs
aide à décider par des grès de régenter
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
provisoire qu'il avait lui-même mais
après avoir dissout l'organe
garantissant l'indépendance de la
justice le chef de l'état a en effet
créé à csm inféodés à sa personne une
décision qui est dénoncé par une partie
des magistrats dont la mobilisation
aurait toutefois échoué d'après le temps
qui voit dans cet échec le résultat de
la capacité de kay sayyed a joué des
divisions si le quotidien se demande où
va la tunisie le site business news lui
n'a aucun doute sur les intentions de
khalis seyed dont le recours en juillet
2021 à l'article 80 de la constitution
aurait annoncé d'emblée la couleur
l'article 80 faisans du président un
dieu tout puissant évoluant dans son
propre univers en modifiant je cite les
règles à sa ligne en pologne les
magistrats persistent à appliquer les
règles européennes au risque d'être
suspendu par le gouvernement
nationaliste mais alors que la cour de
justice européenne devra lever
aujourd'hui le dernier obstacle qui
empêchait la commission de prélever dans
les subventions dues à la pologne et à
la hongrie en raison de leur non respect
de l'état de droit libération raconte ce
matin comme olé j'extrapole honnête
tente de résister au pitch le parti
nationaliste au pouvoir malgré les
sanctions disciplinaires très lourdes
qu'ils encourent et ce sera le sujet du
grand format de parer directes signées
gulliver crack d'ailleurs à 7h50 heure
de paris toujours la rubrique justice
hélène dans un tout autre registre un
accord à l'amiable a finalement été
trouvé entre le prince andrew est la
femme qui l'accuse d'agression sexuelle
en 2001 alors qu'elle était mineure ça
fait la une de toute la presse les
pilotes de cette affaire était en effet
à la une de toute la presse britannique
qui fait état d'un accord financier qui
pourrait atteindre entre 10 et 12
millions de livres un arrangement
honteux pour la plupart des quotidiens
autres manches crise feiner disgrâce sa
disgrâce finale titre de sun tandis que
le daily mail évoque une humiliation à
10 millions de livres et on y reviendra
dans les journaux ou ne se quittent pas
là dessus et là n'est pas question de
vous dira tout à l'heure sans jeter
ainsi la l'équipe qui salue la
prestation de killian bape et lors des
huitièmes de finale aller psg real
madrid le jeune prodige a finalement
surgi dans les toutes dernières minutes
pour offrir la victoire aux parisiens
après le penalty loupé de son camarade
lionel messi d'où le jeunot de l'équipe
mais si c'est encore lui ah ah qu'est
bueno s bape et qu'il est bon se bat p
la presse espagnole elle même est obligé
de s'incliner marcassite la réaction du
joueur je joue pour le psg et j'en suis
très heureux et nous évidemment on est
bien content pour lui face à lille la
ville dans un espagnol exceptionnel ce
qui a quelque peu fait prêter
l'attention du côté de l'autre côté des
pyrénées on en reparlera merci beaucoup
et là on a tout à l'heure dans paris
direct